registration number rb23
call sign Raven authentication complete
status restoring
African
baby something's very special from the
flying Folks at Bandai namcool we have
the omnicore six fires of Rubicon
collector's edition so before we get
into the big boy down here we have
something very special for us Southeast
Asian folk we have a Pfizer Rubicon
controller case which is pretty sick so
let's just look at this real quick
according to the folks at Bandai it can
fit pretty much any control you throw at
it so let's just put it through the test
real quick let me just slowly open this
so I don't screw up okay I screwed it up
really damn it but
okay this looks amazing let's open her
up so you've got a little compartment
down here for you know any wires you
need to charge your controllers but more
importantly is the main bit down here
with a nice little logo or slate with
the armor core 650 Rubicon logo at the
bottom down here let me just grab the
geek control that we have on here we
designed this ourselves so let's just
put it inside and boom
look at that if it's not but what if
it's a PlayStation controller it's in my
pocket
all right
all right PlayStation controller
everything fits inside okay so let's
just put this to the side and now we get
to the best part of the video knife
all right
all right all right okay we've got a
nice little handwritten message from the
book The Bandai thank you guys we love
you a lot all right oh okay it's okay
it's fine look at that
thank you
oh
okay
sorry Abby beautiful wolf look at that
from what I can tell I I think this
might be the collector's edition the one
with the AC stand alone and I think this
is the one with the garage I mean
obviously it's like 32 cm tall if you
want to convert it to Imperials I I
Americans right remove this little
fun
Okay so
in the beginning
very nice references to the main game RB
23 Raven of course Ravens are back baby
so the humans armor core 6 are rather
you the pilot of cosine Raven are a
fourth generation augmented human that's
made to Pilot the AC so let's just get
into this thing honestly the last game I
played was like the last Raven that was
like in 2005 I was
of seven
even know who knows I was eight sorry
okay so slowly it's really oh okay here
here and I do
oh all right so
we have the PS5 copy down here
looking very Swanky this is the Steeler
book
so same Motif as the controller case
that we got in the back it's full
extended art here that's how it looks
like my extended and obviously nothing
inside because of the games here let's
get into this real quick before we get
into the rest of the thing let's see
what's inside because a lot of you all
want to see what's inside the case for
some reason there may be some special
goodies inside not sure opening up for
the first time
do we have a code for the digital
soundtrack and we have a code for the
Melinda C3 Tenderfoot Raven skin slash
Loadout so basically this is a preset of
an AC that you can use in a game like
right out of the box once you get the
code that's pretty much it that's all
that's in the case so moving on we have
a bunch of pins down here for some of
the corporations you will be fighting
under they'll be contracting you and
more importantly we have the Online logo
on here this is the mercenary group or
rather the mercenary support group or
yeah basically you'll find out when you
play the game all right so let's just
pull this out so the pins look like this
very nice and snazzy open the back
send the things to the back here like
this you know they're just pins but
they're really nice oh let me just take
one out actually let's take the all mine
one out nice solid metal tin
okay so put this back in oh what is this
oh okay so we have the armored Core fire
to Rubicon art book
very pretty stuff down here so this is
how the concept art looks like it'll
just turn to another page so you guys
can see what else that's in store for
you and look at the weapons mostly these
are the shoulder mounted weapons and all
right we have a bunch of stickers so
these are stickers or some of the
emblems you can get in game and some of
the ones you can earn from defeating
other ACS inside the arena and these are
the ones you get by default and these
are some of the other ones that you earn
along the way from different
corporations you've got the main logo
down here stickers you have the Ballon
group dolphin all mine but more
importantly Handler Walter is one of the
first few guys you hear over the radio
and you're doing yourself these
emissions but more importantly is the
raven logo because
and now for the main bit
okay it's pretty light okay it is
plastic I believe we will find out
but it feels very light let's put this
box down here
oh
look at that
look at look at that
okay so on the inside the box of the
model the AC model you've got the
different weapons that you have this is
the establishing gun I believe this is
the pal driver melee weapon that you
have and I think it's the assault rifle
another shoulder on the rocket you have
the name of the hit and the body I
believe the Torso and here is a
blueprint design of the Mac that you'll
be getting so the theme continues where
they give you the names of the different
bits of equipment that will be on the AC
model all right same thing on this end
okay
look at that
what a way to come back one day what a
way to come back from software more
importantly what a way to come back I'm
gonna call
all right so in a collector's edition
what's inside here besides the main bits
uh you also have
oh this is a nice little base for the AC
no one's looking pretty good well with
it you know nothing fancy if you're a
painter you can obviously make it look
you know more to what you liking but
it's there all right a bit of plastic
and you also have a nice little backdrop
of the garage
okay
which also doubles as it also doubles as
an instruction booklet
so this is very snazzy stuff coming out
of course it's pure paper you can't
really like slot it in any way I mean
you can do that yourself but yeah it is
what it is so there's no heat to cut
just kind of lift it off and
here's our model
look at that
super duper Swanky very detailed okay so
we're gonna put in the hands now so here
it kind of slots in very nicely there
are specific ways to put it in
so we're going to put that in and then
after that we have the submachine gun
that you get in the game once you're
locked at so now that we've attached the
hands I want to talk a little bit about
articulation uh articulation is
non-existent it really is just a
showpiece nothing kind of moves and
obviously if you put it too high you'll
probably break the thing which is the
last thing that you want all right so
now that we've got articulation out of
the way let's just fit this in so this
has little bits down here to fix it the
back like this here is how it looks like
and now we're gonna head over to the
other hand this is the pile driver all
right I can't remember the name of it
but this is a melee weapon that you can
use and I believe this thing you can
attach it somewhere oh right you attach
this to the side of the um okay there's
a Groove down here to fit into the slide
down here and you just kind of slot it
in from here and now once you've
attached that bit from the hand the
forearm now you can put it in and here
are the shoulder mounted Rockets we are
going to touch the other side
like so
okay
okay so now we're going to replace the
head it's kind of
like that and then we're gonna
and the other ones in customizability
basically just boils down to the kind of
hit that you want but I think that man
looks beautiful so we're gonna get to
the big boy if you're looking for laptop
that does it all gaming streaming and
content creation then look no further
than the Rog surface M16 the first
16-inch laptop with an anime Matrix LED
array so you can showcase your inner
geek to the World featuring a 16x10
aspect ratio QHD Pantone validated Rog
nebula display this display not only
looks great but also offers
unprecedented performance thanks to its
240Hz refresh rate and 3 milliseconds
response time with all that power comes
with full width heatsink supported by
Rog intelligent cooling with tri-fan
technology to keep the laptop cool while
intense gaming or heavy workloads for
more details check out asus.com
beautiful yeah warning labels all around
it's pretty much playing we built danger
science here and there you know your
usual gaming stuff and then let's just
get it open and cut this little seal
here and then boom
this is
the entire tax Edition this is basically
the entire garage these are the
instructions on how to build a garage so
oh this thing is massive look at that
top styrofoam off and this thing really
looks amazing so now we need to take it
off so take the top layer of Styrofoam
off for now this bit here and we've got
a sorry Jimmy it out now look nice
little handles here so very intuitive
design when it comes to the styrofoam
and the packaging I'm gonna put this to
the side
and now
properly off
and the other side
as well
look at that oh there's something here
as well okay that is ridiculous this is
sick okay oh young you're wrong
those are spotlights of fans not it they
don't they don't spin
so inside the styrofoam there is more
stuff got a little doohickey down here I
believe it's a crane
and ah yes these are the parapets so
let's just get this set up somewhere I
am not reading the manual but we don't
do that here in GC all right
part a this thing part B which is
this thing
uh part C and Part D are the two
catwalks
so
um we gotta put in the AC first but
we're not gonna do that because again we
have things so we're going to be taking
this and attaching it to
this
okay it's quite snug I think I kind of
just pushed it a bit out but the thing
is it won't break
and now I'm going to attach it here so
the plastic it doesn't feel cheap but
doesn't feel pure either there's good
enough weathering on the handrails here
and even on the crane arm I believe the
little grooves here as well so just
follow that like this if it's in snugly
and now for this end same thing same
thing
put it right here the AC is assembled
the garage assembled we are going to be
placing the EC inside so you might want
to just remove one
kind of just place it inside
like so a little bit of a snack I don't
think we can put in the setback yeah the
shoulder mounted weapons can go in the
entire figure so just take note of that
oh yep I'll put in the back first okay
all right so we're gonna put the mech in
first
and then we're gonna be putting in
give me the weapon
like so actually show them all the
weapons and the spare head and I believe
this extra bit of terrain here you gotta
place them somewhere else or you know
you can just kind of just put them
around here but obviously you will look
messy so one thing to note there isn't
much space for the shoulder mother
weapons and the spare head over here and
there's nothing on the instructional
sheet to indicate where you'll be
keeping the accessories at so you may
want to put them somewhere safe and
preferably somewhere you won't lose them
okay so let's recap we have the pins
over here we have the steel bookcase we
have the art book over here we also have
the extra bit of terrain at the bottom
here which we're using to put the extra
bits like the short amount of weapons
and the extra hit with the main game we
have the stickers the stickers all here
these are my favorite Parts actually of
any CE and we have the controller
carrying case that's exclusive and here
southeast Asia if you didn't know and of
course
the
AC and the garage with that if you have
any questions about any of the items on
here let us know in the comment section
below and I'll get back to you but more
importantly if you like what we do here
and if you like what you're seeing make
sure to follow us on all of our socials
at the bottom right here to keep up to
date with everything geeky and if you
can leave a like on this video and maybe
subscribe to us it goes a long way in
helping out the channel and if you want
to see more stuff check this out
[Music]
thank you
foreign